okay here's the thing nobody actually
watches an award show
to like see who wins or to like
congratulate the winners
we we watch it to get salty and to feel
like we're part of a conversation like a
sporting event
yeah yeah yeah yeah it is kind of like a
sporting event for like
entertainment right um i mean that's
that's why people watch you know the
anime awards the
gaming awards and also like the oscars
as well which
apparently just aired yesterday and no
nobody watched at the time of recording
at the time of recording it was i didn't
know it aired until the day after
the oscars had yeah i only knew about it
because i saw a tweet of some guy who
like
put down a list of the past 10 years
worth of like viewers
and apparently it's like the lowest in i
think ever
i think it had halfed in one year but
that's also because we didn't really
have any
big theatrical releases we didn't really
have any movies in
2020 most movies went to hbo max or
netflix or whatever and also i feel that
i didn't realize now until this year oh
my god all those ads that these movies
uh
pay for and all the uh like the
promotional tours and whatnot
really do work because i don't know
anything about movies unless they're
doing these like promotional tours
yeah yeah same thing i don't know like
what what i haven't heard i haven't
heard of like a single
really big movie that came out in 2020
obviously because i only knew about the
snyder cut because that was like a meme
because it was fun yeah
the schneiderkill was probably the
biggest kind of movie and then
i was re-releasing it i i think the only
movie i watched
last year not even in cinemas but like
afterwards was tenet
oh yeah in theaters that's really good i
didn't even watch that so [ __ ] good
i know i like i heard so many people
saying it's the most
nolan movie you can ever imagine
it's almost as if uh south park wrote a
parody
of a christopher nolan film and then
they made it like do you know what the
main character is called
uh tell me he's called the protagonist
yeah the main character
is just called the protagonist he
doesn't have a name he's called the
protagonist it's like a [ __ ] initial
issue
the the the [ __ ] even if the story is
kind of dumb
like the visuals in that movie are so
[ __ ] cool yeah yeah oh yeah
it's so good yeah robert patterson i
[ __ ] love i think he's an amazing
actor i will watch it oh yeah
because because i feel like watching
watching tennant i was just like nolan's
obviously just given up on the script
he just has a lot of cool ideas for
visuals and the visuals were [ __ ]
cool
but like pay attention to the plots and
the characters for a second and i'm just
like
what the [ __ ] is going on right now you
know watching it in the movies was like
so exhausting it was literally that was
posing like this
so it's backwards in time okay because
it's pretty good it's really good
it was one of those movies that i
couldn't imagine watching at home i feel
like the big screen i watched at home
broke it it took me like it took me it
took me two times to watch
because the first time i just got really
really bored
in the first half in in the first half
right
because the first half is all plot right
they had us in the first yeah yeah
because like i was like i'm not
following what's going on i really don't
care about it i sleep
have you watched the lighthouse yeah
i've seen that i loved life
uh it's a movie with him and uh who's
the guy played jesus christ um
uh [ __ ] what is his name i will
who can forget his famous reel of ryuk
in definite live action the famous four
lines he said in there yeah yeah
william defer is a [ __ ] amazing actor
and they're both in it and they're both
going crazy it's [ __ ] amazing i won't
spoil it go and watch it
it's kind of an artsy film but it's
really good it's really really good to
watch it how many films do you watch
not many maybe you probably go to the
cinemas though the most out of all of us
though right
yeah but i don't care what i watch at
the movies i'm just like how do you not
care about what you watch
it's just stimulus in my eyes we'll come
back to the oscars we'll talk about that
but yeah okay
because i enjoy just the experience of
the theater
i like the i like the popcorn i like the
fact yeah yeah
how often do you watch films at home oh
never yeah because you're mostly just
like a netflix netflix yeah
because i'm like i'm the complete
opposite i only go to the cinemas if i
know there's a banger
film i need to watch if not i'm just
like i'll just watch it at home
pre-rona i was going like maybe once a
week
maybe once every two weeks damn because
it was just like there was always
something on and um
they would always do reruns so i watched
in japan i watched the shawshank
redemption
in cinemas and cinemas isn't that weird
why would you still watch that at home i
just why not i never got to watch you on
the big screen let's go and have a look
the best film of all time according to
imdb why would i not want to experience
it on the big it's a great film
fantastic
you can also watch i also don't feel bad
if i want to go and get more more
you know drink some popcorn i've already
seen it like 10 times yeah you know so
what you're saying is you just want the
popcorn
i i really okay you want to eat popcorn
can you not eat popcorn at home
ah no not really i i i
legitimately don't go to the movies the
theater now because they don't sell
popcorn in their owner
i don't want to go not because there's a
pandemic
because of the pandemic but if they
let's say the pandemic was still on i
would very
much socially sneak some [ __ ] popcorn
i don't want i don't want to bring my
popcorn i want that pot
you want the overpriced [ __ ] popcorn
it's reasonably priced in japan at least
i i do not want to go i'm sure there's
someone out there who agrees i do not
want to go
to the to the [ __ ] cinema if i'm not
getting popcorn it's not it's
i just don't want it i don't think i've
ever bought popcorn in the cinema i i'll
i'll literally legitimately go to a
restaurant before i'll be full as [ __ ]
i'd be like gagging at how full i am and
i'll be like one large platform
i don't know what's going on yeah yeah
i'll literally be dying but
i do not care i have to go but what i
don't understand is some people
like some some of my friends who you
know we we
go to the movies or we go to the cinema
and it's at this awkward time of like 1
or 1 30 you know
and it's just like do you eat lunch
before or do you not eat lunch before
and some people are just like
the popcorn is my lunch i'm just like
how the [ __ ] is popcorn like popcorn
is not anything i'm pretty sure you
can't even live off popcorn now
it's not it's not a meal pressure is
negative calories
right right it feels like it when you're
just eating
air